es una guerra de acusaciones entre
demócratas y republicanos se culpan
mutuamente de los violentos episodios
que sacuden a varias ciudades de eeuu
el presidente no puede detener la
violencia porque durante años la ha
fomentado puede creer que pronunciar las
palabras ley orden lo hacen fuerte pero
su incapacidad para llamar a sus propios
seguidores para que dejen de actuar como
una milicia armada en ese país demuestra
lo débil que es wikileaks
para el presidente de donald trump los
alcaldes y gobernadores demócratas de
estos territorios han perdido el control
acabo de escuchar lo que baten tenía que
decir para mí está culpando a la policía
mucho más que a los alborotadores
anarquistas agitadores y saqueadores a
los que nunca podría culpar o perdería a
la izquierda radical que apoya a ver que
la casa blanca confirmó que trump
viajará aquí nos ha nuevo epicentro de
tensiones y protestas a raíz de la
muerte de jake blake un hombre negro que
recibió siete disparos en la espalda por
parte de un policía
la portavoz del mandatario no descartó
ni confirmó si trump se reuniría con la
familia de blade actualmente los planes
son reunirse con la
local y algunos dueños de negocios y él
examinará los daños pero próximamente se
anunciarán planes más detallados pero el
alcalde de esta ciudad de wisconsin dijo
que es mejor que la visita de trump se
ve en otro momento sus residentes temen
que la presencia del presidente pueda
despertar más emociones y traer más
violencia esto en medio de las protestas
contra el racismo y las manifestaciones
pro trump que terminan en disturbios y
tiroteos mortales tanto en portland como
en chicago